We're back and here with Gary tan.
So we're going to be talking more about VC stuff. Cause, um,
I have a lot of friends who say that ultimately they want to end up being a
VC investor. Totally. Is that how we say VC investor.
A venture capitalists? Sure. A VC.
Their reasoning is that they don't really want to do the work of building
things, but they want to, um, advise people and, you know,
think about what would be a good product. And then.
Oh my God, I guess I would tell them don't do it. Okay. Yeah,
because then you'll end up being remember earlier in the,
in the episode we were talking about their investors who lead and they make up
their own minds. And then there are people who just check, check, check,
check the box, and then only want to, you know,
invest when it's absolutely a sure thing. Right. But I guess even okay.
Say they do want to, like, they do want to lead. Yeah. They still want to lead.
Right. I don't know if I'm, um, relined or messages correctly,
but for me it sounds like, uh, they don't really want to do the work. Right.
They want to do the purely intellectual thing,
which is obviously there's so much work though. That's what I was thinking.
So can you tell me about like your day to day or?
Yeah, totally. Um, I mean, VC had done right.
Is literally like your schedule is like, you know,
9:00 AM to 6:00 PM or honestly I have kids now. So, you know,
if I didn't,
I probably do be doing like literally like 7:00 AM till like
2:00 AM, you know, just things all day. Right. Uh,
but now that I do have two young children,
I have to actually cut it back to like, well, get to office at nine.
I have to leave by five cause I gotta pick up my four-year-old. Right. Um,
and of course I can get a few hours in the evening,
but I better sleep because you know,
my five month old is going to cry all night.
And so honestly this job done right. Will actually feel, uh,
any amount of space that you give it. And so it is a lot of work to do it,
right. Because, uh, every other day, um,
someone lost their best customer. They lost their director of engineering. Uh,
you know, someone somewhere in my portfolio,
people are getting punched in the face and you know,
on that day when maybe the company is going to die, I have to pick up the phone.
I can't just be like decline. Right.
So what do you have to do? Like if a company dies, it's not like you have it,
somebody you have a say on what they have to do.
So what do you do to prevent that?
Yeah, a lot of it is how do we find a better person? Like if we're,
if it's personnel, like how do we recruit?
How do we hire get me on the phone with this person,
if it's a losing a customer, like let's find other customers,
let's make a spreadsheet of a hundred other people who could fill in that hole.
And let's, um, you know,
we'll actually come through all nine partners at initialized,
their whole networks. And then we'll,
we actually built software for this to basically get customers and uh,
hire people for our companies. And so all of these things are a lot of work.
Like we kind of run it like a startup itself.
Yeah. I actually had no idea that VCs were such help. Well, we do it this way.
There a few other people.
Who do it like that Andreessen Horowitz is known to have, you know,
probably more than a hundred people who work as an operating company on behalf
of their founders. Oh, that's really cool. Yeah. We have nine.
So we're just getting.
Started. Okay. So you called these operators, right?
Yeah. Operating partners, but you know,
every single one of our operating partners also can do their own deals and bring
in companies. Um, they're not expected to, but you know,
we want them to learn how to do the business.
Okay. So what kind of people would be, would become good VCs? Yeah.
Honestly, great founders are sort of the best because, um,
those are the people who can actually help. Like when something happens,
it's just not, you know, totally new, you know,
I don't have to call in a favor from my network. It's like, Oh, when I,
when I had that problem, here's what I did. Um,
and that's just more useful when you're trying to avoid the landmines. Um,
and so the best version of that is actually start a company.
And even if it doesn't work out, like you'll have learned so much, uh,
the next best thing honestly, is join a fast growing company, uh, as it's,
you know, sort of in hypergrowth. Um,
here's a really useful a rule of thumb for your viewers. Um, you can basically,
if you wanted to evaluate any startup the way a VC does,
just figure out what the growth rate is. Um, and this might be revenue,
it might be users. Um, it depends on what the company is, but,
uh, basically for seed to series a,
if they're growing three acts a year, um, that's pretty good.
Like that's sort of like a solid B um, anything, four X and above.
That's like an, a, like a five is like a plus it's like five X a year, really,
really hard to sustain. And then anything growing around two X,
like C plus C, like, you know,
and this is sort of a measure of why startups are so hard,
like literally startups are growth.
And if you've ever tried to grow something like by two or even two X a year,
that's really hard. Um, but that's sort of how people can evaluate as a,
you know, a non VC, the, you just figure out how fast that thing is growing.
And that'll actually tell you whether your startup is living or dying.
They're like sharks. Basically. They have to keep growing.
Otherwise they'll die. They have to keep moving. Otherwise they'll die. Yeah.
Yeah. So for engineers and PMs currently, yeah. Um,
if they want to go into VC,
then the best thing they should do is join a startup or even start your own
startups so that they can build empathy for the startups that they will invest
in. Right. Absolutely.
And then it's about that story. Like, you know,
what did you do for that company? And, you know,
a lot of people jump over to VC because they're the person who they were the
growth PM for something that grew from like a million users to a hundred million
users. And that's the kind of experience that is like almost impossible to get.
And those are the people who are deeply sought after in the world for their
advice. And so, you know, that's why joining a fast growing startup,
sometimes it's even better than starting your own,
cause it's really hard to start your own. So if they have all the skills.
They, how does it work in terms of the money?
Because I don't really understand how the VC world works.
So do you usually try to join a VC firm and then pay your stake so that you
could be a managing partner or operating partner? How does it work?
How do you even join one?
Yeah, absolutely. Um, I think there are kind of a few different paths.
The first one would be, um, you know, work as an operator,
maybe early in your career, find some sort of when,
like I was the person who scaled, like, you know, this 10 X at, you know,
this fast growing company. Um, and then early in people's career,
they could join as an associate at a venture capital firm. And, um, you usually,
you have to find your way to network in, to meet the person.
A lot of is just purely trust, right?
If people think you're smart and scrappy and hungry, um,
and you know, they've met you like sometimes they're just going to hire you.
Like the next time they have an associate. The next level is sort of principals.
I mean, these are people who sort of start as VCs, um,
and then get promoted once.
And those are people who start taking more investing responsibility,
associates tend to do mainly sourcing. So, you know,
sometimes going to events or, you know,
going into Excel spreadsheets or writing software to basically go,
come through the internet and figure out what's happening,
what are companies that could be good opportunities. And then they'll work with,
um, you know, the general partner, uh, or, you know, the,
basically the investing partner to bring that to the whole team. And so,
you know, the associate role is not that glamorous,
but it's kind of like starting out in any business.
It starts out as you kind of have to do like the SCUP work. And then as you go,
uh, associate principal, um,
sometimes there's a managing director role and then, you know,
making partner is kind of what it sounds like it's a really big deal because
only then do you really get a significant part of sort of the winnings from a
given fund, we call that carry in the business. Um,
so only after you returned the whole fund, um,
the partners tend to get 20 to 30% of, uh,
anything after you returned the money to your limited partners,
limited partners are the people who give you money to invest.
Got it. Okay. So for example, for initialized capital, you and Alexis,
you guys are the founding partners, right?
And then you guys probably put in your own money at first that's right.
And then you guys have bunch of, I guess,
associates that maybe become principal and then maybe a partner.
We just have partners. You guys just have partners. Okay, cool.
So they have partners. So they put a stake in,
do they have to like pay an amount to be in it or like invest your own money?
Oh, I mean,
we're basically investing on behalf of some of the biggest endowments and
institutions in the world. So the universities, you know,
when you watch PBS and you hear about, you know, X foundation and Y foundation,
uh,
they're large pools of capital that are billions of dollars that are basically
run, uh, often to support some sort of non-profit or some sort of, um, you know,
university, some sort of big goal. Uh,
those are pools of capital that have to grow in order to actually support their
mission. So, uh, you know,
Harvard or Stanford or any university that has an endowment, um,
they actually can't spend the money that they have when you hear about Harvard
having $38 billion,
they can't just take a dollar out of that endowment and just, uh, you know,
give someone a scholarship.
They actually have to go and give that to other investors and those, you know,
private equity or hedge funds or, you know, fidelity,
there's so many ways to invest. And then venture capital, uh,
is crazy because it's only, you know, something like 1% or, you know,
all of venture capital is, uh, only a hundred billion dollars a year.
Whereas the total amount of money going in through the financial system is
easily in the trillions. And so, uh,
everything that we talk about with venture capital,
it's basically this tiny mote of dust on this vast ocean of finance.
And there's more capital in the world than people know what to do if at this
point, which is like mind boggling for me.
Like if you told the 15 year old me that there's more money in the world than
anyone knows what to do with,
I wouldn't believe you because we didn't have money and how, you know.
And so that's one of the core problems in society today. It's like,
how do these giant pools of capital actually put it towards, you know,
businesses that employ people that actually have useful for society?
So that's why venture capital is probably one of the most important businesses.
And I'm, you know, I'm glad people want to do it,
but the best venture capitalists are probably people who also started their own
too, so they can actually help them.
It's a lot of sense.
Can you tell me a little bit of the timeline for initialized capital?
Like how much money you've raised and now they,
how much you've grown and stuff like that, just to get.
Yeah, totally. Uh,
we started off with a small $7 million fund about seven years ago,
and now we have over $500 million under management.
Um, our newest fund is $225 million.
So we will write checks of a million dollars to $5 million, uh,
in exchange for about 15% of companies. Um,
and so we'll lead and we'll do the whole round. And, you know, if we,
if we write a really big check, we'll sit on the board, um,
and that was very different.
Like we are a true institutional venture capital firm before now,
but before we actually started kind of like angels,
like we were writing a $50,000 checks, $25,000 checks. And even then I was like,
that's a crazy amount of money. Um, but we were writing them into companies, uh,
as the first check and those companies became billion dollar companies.
And so that kept happening and we realized, well,
instead of sending 20 or 30 emails to all everyone else saying, Hey,
this is a good company. You should invest in it. We just write one check,
the founder is done and then we get back to work. Right.
And that was sort of the evolution of us from going tiny checks and helping
other people to helping other investors to, well, we'll just do the whole thing.
So what were some of your biggest wins personally that you have
rewarded yourself financially the most?
I mean, honestly, I participant super lucky. Like for me,
Stanford was pretty crazy because the people you got to meet, I mean,
you went to Waterloo,
like the people you get to sit next to people who are going to go on and do all
kinds of insane stuff. And when I was there, I had no idea. Okay. So.
I guess what I meant was like,
what was your best exit and how much did you make up? Yeah.
Yeah. So I've actually never talked about this,
but we did sell postures for $20 million. Co-founders uh,
two co-founders.
Okay. Okay. And did you have initial investors?
Yes, we did. Um, and we'll tell you how much I actually made. Um,
but I can tell you how, uh, as a VC,
I try and figure out how much people made from a given exit. Um,
so obviously you have the acquisition price, and then again,
going back to cap table, um,
you can kind of guess most co-founders are probably close to equal,
but not always, but assuming that it makes the math easier if everyone's equal.
Um, and then basically count the number of funding rounds they've done. Um,
if it's an early round, like a seed round or a series, a, uh,
sometimes a series B it's about 20% of dilution, meaning, uh,
investors came in and bought 20% of the company at that moment.
And then the founders and the employees would only own 80% after that funding
round.
So if you had 50% and then after one funding round, you would have 40.
Yeah, exactly. Um, and then you can count them up, basically the series CS,
C D E like G you know, they go on for awhile these days. Um,
those tend to go from, you know, 10% for the B uh,
down to sometimes just one or 2% for the much later rounds.
So almost all of the dilution is actually usually in the seed series a and B.
I see. Okay. Just mostly in B. So if you.
Ever wanted to do the math,
just count the percentages and then do the math and multiply it by the, uh,
acquisition price. And that's how much that person probably made.
And I'm sorry for asking this question, but what about being a VC?
How much can you make from that, given the success?
I'll tell you how to do the math for that too. All right.
Um, let's make the math easy. Say,
say VC has a hundred million dollar venture capital fund.
So they raised a hundred million dollars from other people. Um,
and then a lot of people often ask, like, how much does the VC usually put in?
So, um, it varies. It's sometimes as low as 1%. Um,
w you know, sometimes it's as high as I think, um,
Peter teal is putting in 20% of the billion and a half dollar fund that he's
raising for founder's fund or has raised. So it varies.
So for a hundred million dollar fund,
that the people who run that fund might only put a million dollars in total.
And then what happens is they invest that over usually two to three
years. Uh, and then 10 sort of 10 to 15 years from, from,
uh, that they're kind of expected to give back something like between,
uh, surprisingly a low number of like maybe two X or three X, two X,
two X to three X is basically, um,
considered a pretty decent fund. Uh,
so meaning investors gave them a hundred million and they have to give back 200
to $300 million in the next 10 to 15 years. I see. Um,
and then the typical carry for a VC fund is 20 to 30%.
And so, uh, all of the VC partnership, if they own it,
if it's only a two X fund would make about $20 million. Nice. Thanks for that.
So it's really simple numbers, but it is an incredible job, right?
That's what it's finance is crazy. Um,
so friends of mine actually started a company with Peter teal in 2004.
And, um, I was 22 years old, just graduated.
Um,
didn't know anything about money or how companies started to know anything about
venture capital.
I got my first full-time job with Microsoft up in Seattle program manager,
program manager for windows mobile, weirdly enough, um, you know, two,
three years before the iPhone, uh, ever came out.
And so I saw them just kind of try and copy designs,
like literally copying, like the checkbox mentality of, um, you know,
here's what rim does. Let's just copy it. But it was my first job.
I had health insurance, uh, you know,
I actually could have a really nice apartment.
I ran out and bought a new car and, um, and then my friends called and said,
Hey, you got to quit your job. Uh, we're starting a company with Peter teal.
You know, the guy, I mean, and Peter teal was not a billionaire yet.
I think he had just sold PayPal. Um,
he was probably worth like tens of millions of dollars at that point,
which was still like insane. And he said, well, come have dinner with me.
I flew down to San Francisco. He had just opened a French restaurant. Uh,
the French restaurant was bad. It was terrible. The French restaurant. Yeah.
I mean, it's one of those things. When you sell a company, you know,
you buy the flashy car, you open your own restaurant. Like, you know,
you get it all out of your system. That's fun. It's called free zone.
It was terrible. The restaurant closed almost immediately,
but it was about the time he wrote the $500,000 check to Facebook that made him
a billion dollars, or it made him a true billionaire.
And I had met him a bunch of times. I hadn't come to speak at Stanford.
So it wasn't like, I didn't know who this person was. It was like,
clearly a Silicon Valley legend.
And here he was having dinner with me the 22 year old, you know,
pro program manager. He's like, Gary, what the hell are you doing at Microsoft?
You're wasting your life. Um,
I'm so sure you quitting your job and joining the startup is the right thing.
He got out his personal checkbook and he said, um,
I'm gonna write you a check for $70,000,
which is my whole annual salary in 2004, uh, which is more money than I'd ever,
you know, I was probably $40,000 in, uh, in debt, um, you know,
student loans and credit cards and all that. It's like, um,
and cause because I ran out and I didn't treat money like, um, you know,
capital and time I treated it as well.
I deserve this because I have a job now and you know, the job's really hard,
so I should have nice stuff.
I'd like basically fell into that trap of being lulled into like the physical,
having nice things, you know? Um, and the problem was,
I felt like I couldn't take the risk. It was crazy. Right. Um, I had, you know,
and so he said, you're here, take this check. I'm sure this is right.
I got on a plane back to Seattle. And I said, no.
And that company became Palentier, uh, which is, you know,
worth 20 to $40 billion depending on who you talk to. And so easily,
uh, the equity from that, if I had joined at that moment as a first engineer,
it would have been worth probably close to $200 million. Um,
and that's the kind of decisions.
Those are the kinds of decisions that people have to make. Uh,
when you're a maker, it's completely crazy. Um, but it's commonplace.
You spend any time in,
around here and you just get run into people who literally say no to the next
Facebook or no, sorry.
Actually say no to actually Google or actually Facebook actually. Yeah.
But that's also kind of the crazy thing about tech now.
It's like we are touching every part of society, uh, with software.
And so I don't know, I spent a lot of time trying to decide,
like why did I make that crazy $200 million mistake?
And, um, that it was just.
Well, I mean, you're doing pretty well right now, so I think it's not that bad.
Yeah. But, um, it's a good, did end up going,
you did end up working for Palentier. Yeah. I just joined a year later,
a year later. So I mean,
I guess that's a big difference in terms of like equity percentages, but yeah,
totally. But yeah. So I guess that was still pretty fruitful for you.
You designed a logo. That was cool.
That was fun. And I got to see what it was like, you know,
what made me quit was actually seeing all of my friends who were way smarter
than me, uh, quit. They're like I had a friend, uh,
Bob McGrew who quit his PhD at Stanford. And I said, well, you know,
Microsoft is a big deal, but you know, PhD at Stanford is a bigger deal. And,
um,
that's kind of what you ended up finding with a lot of these startups is I like
to say that it's kind of like packing a snowball.
Do you like a nineties,
nineties vintage video games? Like for Sony PlayStation?
I wasn't born, ah. Okay.
Okay. There's this game called? Katamari Damacy uh,
I think it might be like early two thousands. Maybe.
That's on the ball. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's basically, yeah.
What a startup is like actually a, you start out with this tiny,
like in the game, you're an alien and you're about this high and you know,
you're probably smaller than this, this cap. Right.
You know, we'll have a prop here actually. Oh yeah, totally. This is all around.
It's rolling around. And then the, the deal is, um.
A little alien rolling around a ball and anything that, uh,
you are bigger than you pick up and then it becomes a boop like a part of you.
And then you can pick up bigger things and anything that is too big and you try
and hit it. Uh, you'll actually bounce off and you'll get smaller.
And that's basically what a startup is all the time.
So getting a first customer hiring your co-founder,
hiring your first engineers, raising your first money. Um,
that's all you're doing. Like it's like little bottle caps and things like that,
sticking onto your ball. And then, you know,
the funny thing about this game is by the last few levels, you know,
you start picking up tables, you pick up like buildings, cars by the end,
you're actually picking up whole continents. And so that's kinda, you know,
startups are basically Katamari Damacy and you know,
that's what you'll find in these patterns. It's like hiring is really important.
Raising money is really important,
but then the most important thing is actually getting customers like that,
that telling that story, well, we'll get you all of the rest. You'll, you know,
you'll get people to drop what they're doing and come join this thing.
Cause Hey, this is a rocket ship. That's about to.
Gotcha.